there's no shortage of orange in
Amsterdam right now and no shortage of
royal-themed paraphernalia people are
gearing up for the big day on April
thirtieth when Queen Beatrix passes on
the crown to her son vilem Alexander
student Brom house German just can't
wait and he'll certainly be dressing up
for the occasion I'm not dressed up at
all like this I of course we are
something orange I've been orange polo I
have some orange get long as I've orange
glasses i always take them with me
that's important for me one thing he
doesn't have yet is a suitable t-shirt
there's going to be a new king this year
after all yes for him being more like a
king it's a very royal hair dress as we
know it the Dutch people so I guess this
will suit him well I think I will yeah
just wear orange is everywhere even in
food and drink and the incoming king is
a big fan of beer one Brewer decided to
honor him with a specially created
Majesty pilsner
I've I open up the organic on campu of
course we hope the camera try it this in
the premium or that you like it built
it's an organic pilsner made from
organic products below she put the power
to power we're very proud of its great
taste I'm he left also and I don't know
whose hilaire lega then there's one of
the country's biggest exports Gowda
cheese get hot rods is a cheese maker
and as a good Patriot concocted his very
own royal version for the occasion it's
become a best-seller this is the the
yellow cheese it's handmade it from the
farm and then we thought now we make it
orange with red white blue our flag our
penis on it and with the King Alexander
is coming I hope he comes to taste it
meanwhile brahms outfit is gradually
taking shape it's not easy given the
selection of items available
yeah that's kind of a classic or oak Oh
especially this one is Gil on that we
all like this one's a little bit hard
since it's the end of April not a very
hot already in the Netherlands and then
I have this very classical cowboy hat
it's not very dark force but it's a
little bit of a classy item with some
bling bling on top also very popular and
it's wick the good thing is it has some
purely hair like many Dutch cheese have
the Royal theme sector is booming adding
an estimated three million euros a day
to retailers turn over the Royal hand
over which coincides with the Queen's
Day public holiday means huge business
for Amsterdam this is a unique
opportunity this royal state occasion 33
years for the last time and now again so
it's a very it's a very good marketing
opportunity for the city you can't pay
that publicity that's wonderful but it's
not just about being seen but seeing as
well Brom already has plans for watching
the coronation
we have to be there very early so we
have to get up early and afterwards we
just go and enjoy the city go to
Sepphoris square it's not just that we
gather at one place we just walk around
a little there are many venues open many
cool stages nice performance is very
very good to all brom needs now is that
final touch some face paint and on the
big day he won't be the only one seeing
the world through orange colored glasses
you